hey guys how's it going it's Justine and
we're in my kitchen today so to start
this off when I think about Halloween I
think about candy corn I actually really
I really hate candy corn I think it
tastes disgusting but no better way to
celebrate by making something that I
don't like then a frozen popsicle a
candy corn pudding pop I think these
will taste a lot better than the candy
least I'm hoping so anyway so since
we're making pudding pops we need
pudding now in this recipe that I found
on the Internet
it's saying that we need a small box and
a large box you need some bowls so it
says to use a white chocolate flavor for
the white layer but for the life of
thing I couldn't find it I also didn't
plan on going to the store so this was
basically whatever I could get same day
on Amazon and this is what I found
jello it's also sugar-free and fat-free
that sounds like it's gonna taste like
trash smells good
I usually don't like to measure but I'm
going to because I would like this to be
good
there's there's one cup oh god I've
already made a mess heavy a container of
milk all I need is I think this is
supposed to be connected to something
that's okay let's mix this up
that looks pretty white during one
teaspoon of honey and then it says to
transfer it to a large plastic bag why
would I do one teaspoon of honey
[Music]
oh it's starting to get hard it's
starting to get like putting like
putting back like two seconds ago this
was this was not this consistency I have
made pudding before so this is not my
first time this is not my first rodeo
okay that one looks great to me let's
put this it yeah this is definitely a
different color than that one this is
[Music]
one that's you and a half I have to
color one of the bull yellow and then
one of the other ones or I'm gonna put a
little little disappear okay I think
that's good okay
I mean it already looks yellow to me so
why not add a little bit more of this
delicious artificial flavoring more or
less to taste I've got my color wheel
here let's mix that up this looks gross
this looks disgusting
disgusted Oh
my god I'm starting to cry it's really
emotional to be thinking back to all the
times that I've had candy corn and how
gross it tastes okay I'll put this in a
bag I put it in the bag I have a wet leg
now because the doll just went to me
[Music]
so you put your pudding in a little
baggie like so this is gonna help us
when we put it in the in the popsicle
molds I do not I do not mix that low
enough
[Music]
it's not getting hard like the other one
oh it's vanilla rice pudding grasa do
something wait oh shoot I have to cook
this I have to cook it I don't know I
thought instant shoot baal-zebub the
plans are have changed we've altered the
course of the universe so stupid it's
really just ruin oh that's that fire
still on God almost burned all my hair
off oh I think I might have actually all
right we're back the pudding has been
chilling for quite a long time in
refrigerator and now we're gonna
actually make these clicking things
first thing you're gonna want to do is
get your ice pops pop them down like so
get your bags you're gonna fill the rest
of your bags up with your colorful
pudding oh this looks so gross
who likes candy cool ok bag full would
move on to this other color I'm probably
gonna at this point be able to make one
single pop we're gonna cut one little
end of the bag and then we're gonna just
school easy I wasn't ready I wasn't
ready
oh squeeze it into the bottom everything
just in theory sounds like a really
excellent idea
[Music]
cut this little end like a so I'm gonna
squeeze that in just like so
[Music]
that's real that's us chunky we're gonna
take these top so we're gonna shove them
in there real good real nice just give
it a nice shove this one's gonna
overflow for sure you know if you guys
remember how long ago I made those
previous pudding pops they're still in
the freezer next to the dog ice cream
[Music]
all right this is the moment that I have
been waiting for that I'm sure all of
you have been waiting for probably not
at all because magic of editing it's
only been probably like that and real
quick we're about they go into the
freezer for our pudding pie Oh Cheers
the crowd is going absolutely nuts Hey
[Music]
here we go yes oh my goodness this looks
not like the photo yet again common
theme oh gosh so cold I don't think this
is something that I'd be like you know
what I'm really craving a frozen pudding
pop
and really it all pays the same flavor
it's all vanilla that it doesn't taste
like it's just colored happy Halloween
in the picture it wasn't completely
covered not that it matters you can do
whatever you want this is this is
something you just use your creativity
you can do whatever you want this is a
recipe developed for all ages all skill
level